welcome to this video playing dr. John
Newman a legend of chess probably one of
the strongest players in the world in
the 1980s though he's retired from
competitive chess and is some
responsible form for very nice chess
books some is also an official maybe
even the boss I'm not quite sure of
gambit publications and it's still a
very strong player he's also strong in
blitz playing often here on on ICC I
played a very safe like the h3 exchange
variation it's um the kind of line where
you can hardly lose but you can always
try a bit okay so I forgot what's going
on here h6
hmm if it if you would have taken a
swoop d8 of course do I take now hmm
yeah I think I take I am really forgot
what what is played him he cannot take
twice on c3 84 because of Ruby 8 again
so I'm a grown-up but black M has a good
piece play as compensation normal would
be something like a lightly an idea or
night a six she's going to c5 this is
the intention I need to keep this
protected I need to play f3 to make sure
that I keep the porn
I have made some positional concessions
for winning the point of course the dark
squares i weakened quite a lot and it's
mostly a defensive task now try to
control the position and make sure that
it's not getting the pawn bag under
favor of circumstances okay so I need to
need to go here get rid of this Bishop
and it's nice this Bishop this light on
on c5 okay opening up the position and
maybe here too
to protect it help protecting the Queen
side okay if I go Bishop e2 takes on c4
Bishop c4 takes takes root before right
looks okay
I should have firm I should have enough
fear I mean we know now no big big
problems I mean I could also take and
play 95 if this isn't so bad
even habit maybe just just develop you
have just just develop I can
click here later anyway I don't think
that taking on c4 is doing him much good
Bishop takes until we exchange bishops
it should be helpful and upon up after
all oh this this actually allows me to
take and play 95 why could go rook d6
trying to yeah it looks good for me in
any case okay let's let's do this and go
95 this is this is simple and good yeah
I actually saw that him I thought this
would be would be good no b3 was hanging
so this was was clear that it's a
possibility I know I don't know if he's
active enough to get out of this
okay you people can't bats get out of
the sea for they will put something on
the CFL anyway so I need to get get out
of this with the king beautiful
okay he's attacking strong move Roxy to
a merman and opinion with Roxy seven and
before oh I can play this now if he
takes rook F 1 I'm winning the bishop
and if you go swish of f6 I play e5 now
94 36 this looks very nice now yeah I
hope I'm managing this one I really
would like to have this whip this win
there are g3 is the threat winning the
bishop I need to move the rook somewhere
now rook t6m I think attacking the the
weakness new pt7 and I still have g3 i I
want to G three years yeah he goes now
he needs to go to e7
and then after route d7 I haven't really
an in a box here right D six threatened
so just okay I just just just to just
improve it a bit more get the King
involved should I get the night - and
it's make sure that she doesn't have
focus yet even the question is how to
how to know and improve that it's I just
hear and now look a six
I didn't see that one coming
but hopefully it's not not so oh and I
can I can even check him so I can check
I thought this what just win doesn't it
he's got four beautiful no no no I'm
quick enough here to pick up oops the
queenside wow this was nice okay I bet
it probably slipped up somewhere in the
technical face but I think it was it was
decent now yeah this this kind of
position is it's probably am around
equal but it's not so so easy to get to
play for both sides maybe this is this
is not the way to go and I'm not sure I
mean it looks nice to to play such an
aggressive move but maybe it's not
really helping him there's also always
this issue with the Boosters taking I
mean I could have taken now on b5
no I look bishops these six computers
also giving but okay this is how this is
right I think yeah here before it's an
alternative but I want to get get out of
the C file yeah this wasn't was a
bedroom I mean I mean not probably not
spoiling too much but I overlooked this
but now this was really a big mistake in
f7 he needs to do something else
rook a7 look somewhere I don't know I
just
just Bishop back to have six or
something but this is this allows f4 and
after this so it's probably winning for
white which I probably didn't didn't
prove 100% g3 is even stronger him yeah
but it's it's it's very it's very good
good for white maybe I should have
played a 7 then the speaking opponent
gave us really lost now I overlooked
actually rookie for here he could have
played rupee for it's not it's not great
or anything but this at least doesn't
loose immediately and this is this does
lose I mean now yeah I could have played
h5 but ok it's it's just one point that
you can earn in one game
yeah thanks for watching